foreign
Cody joins us up next in Atlanta Georgia
Cody welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you how are you guys doing doing
great how can we help
hey I'm trying to find out whether or
not I need to pretty much sell my car
um I played the credit card game pretty
stupidly uh racked up you know
the junk
um has paid it all off have about eight
thousand dollars in cash less add
another in total return in my life seven
thousand dollars in student loans and
combined we make about 80. and we just
had a uh a kid about four months ago
congrats and we oh thank you thank you
we owe about 25
000 on a brand new 2022.
wow what car is it
uh Chevy Equinox okay
and how what's your total debt all I
heard was the student loans in there
um nothing
we don't own a house the car is our only
debt oh the car is the only guy okay you
had mentioned student loans but I guess
you said you paid that off
no we have 7 000 in student loans we
paid off all the credit cards okay
that's just a quick definition of debt
owing anything to anyone for any reason
is there any other debt you want to tell
us about I think he said it I think he
said seven thousand in student loans
yeah but then I said is that it is it's
just the car sticking up for you Cody
okay Cody I'm just trying to get my
ducks in a row here so we got 7 000
student loans 25 000 on the car and
you're wondering if you should sell the
car to get out of all this debt
feel like I'm asking a stupid question
no there's no stupid questions no you're
not I want to get my details straight so
we can help you yeah so what's the car
worth
pretty much the loan trade in value
whatever on the loan is what it's worth
now okay so it's equal it's worth 25 you
owe 25.
correct it would be a loss for me
um and I'm just wondering especially in
today's market especially since we have
besides the student loans we have no
other debt but we also want to save up
for a house so it's kind of okay what
they do you know and especially we've
even thought about selling a car and not
having a car we both work from home
we're like if there's an emergency call
9-1-1
so this is your only car
yes oh yeah no we need a car I would
yeah okay I'm a car up there with like a
at least one at least one now you have
eight thousand in the bank you said
right
said the question correct so for me Cody
the rule of thumb always is if you can't
pay off your car in 18 to 24 months you
need to sell it do you think you guys
can pay off 20 25 000 in debt and in a
year to year and a half
we probably could
but we want to do it sooner okay so
that's my question so you could keep the
car yeah and you guys could pay it off
you know total two years would be the
the most but maybe if you could do it in
a year year and a half but if you don't
want to go through the pain of all of
that yeah you have an asset right there
that you can trade in take some of the
savings you guys would get a a beat or
it would not be a great car but you're
talking about selling the car anyway so
I don't think you're too concerned with
it uh and then and then throw some money
at the student loan get that paid off
then then save back up to pay for a car
so all of that would be the route you
would go versus just decreasing your
lifestyle dramatically
um to pay it off but you're going to be
decreasing your lifestyle anyways Cody
to uh to get some money to you know get
that beater and to pay off your student
loans and then to save up for another
car if you want to replace the beater so
yeah so to recap Cody what would we do
today if you decide I'm going to sell
this car sell the car for 25 the loan's
gone now take maybe 7 000 of the 8 000
you have in the bank go get yourself a
reliable used car and then you're at
baby step two paying off those seven
thousand student loans and you can do
that much more quickly right we're
talking a few months
correct yeah so it speeds up the process
by a year and a half yep
which I think excites you more at this
point which is great
yeah well especially because we don't
have a ton in retirement 401K which I'll
you know yep and almost our 30s kind of
scares us a little well you got time man
you guys are still young you got this so
I think you know what to do anytime
someone's willing to sell the car I know
I'm like all right that's a hard
emotional place to get to and if it
speeds up the journey because the
Journey's tough two years of really
sacrificing versus for a car yeah a car
is an is a reversible decision in some
points because you know you can just get
rid of it I can't sell my student loans
sell the piece of paper and get money
back so that is the nice thing about
that but uh we're wishing you the best
Cody